à
[Musique]
temps pour toi je crois que mon anneau
contraceptif est tombé quoi c'est pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il est plus là tu
arrives à sentir ce n'est pas dans le
bonheur
tu sais que tu as de la chance
des libres et pas moi hélas on est sur
pilotage automatique un truc comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est des fusées sur tes bras certains
trouvent ça adorable
[Applaudissements]
pas sortir avec il est ce que réellement
vous sortez ensemble oui je dirais pas
qu'on sort vraiment ensemble
noyer de la part de va augmenter en
septembre on pourrait habiter au simple
je veux pas qu'on s'installe ensemble
les choses ne vont pas bien
[Musique]
je viens de rompre avec le mec que
j'étais censé épouse et non non non on
va pas plus loin qu'est ce qui te ferait
plaisir
montre-moi des photos de sushis s'te
plaît tissu
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression cui là et moi on est
dans l'impasse
j'ai vu vos textos mais de quoi tu
parles je sens plus ou moins avec
quelques m oblige à regarder ta petite
série débile j'aimais ça en fait tu
viens de perdre un spectateur man pâtit
[Musique]
nettement dans une vie
mais combien de personnes tu t'entends
vraiment bien
n'était que le côté si on se faisait un
brunch
[Musique]
mon ex n'aurait jamais laissé garder
mais saute dans la voiture maintenant je
peux y accéder quand je veux ça sent
vraiment bizarre ici c'est l'odeur de la
liberté mon ami
[Musique]